meanwhile i'm sitting there and i'm
looking around the room
thinking holy mackerel i am in the oval
box
[Music]
professor david demaris thank you so
much for being on 20 minute leaders
happy to be here such an honor to have
you here i you know you're one of my
one of my favorite favorite professors
of my one year at stanford but i'm sure
looking back at the four years that
you're still going to be one of my
favorite professors because the amount
of inspiration
that you gave me and i think 19 others
in the class
is just unparalleled to what we could
have hoped for
a professor demoris you were a they had
one of the head of communications for
the bush and george bush senior
administration and the white house
bank of america visa with branding and
communications and an expert on strategy
i just want to hear stories over these
20 minutes and hear
you know some of the incredible lessons
that you taught us professor can you
tell me a little bit about where you
came from and how you even got
to be in communications for george bush
senior
well um i have been active uh in
politics generally
for a number of years um helping to
rebuild
uh what was then a struggling political
party meaning the republican party in
the late 70s
and uh had some success doing that
reagan was elected in 1980 and
my boss who is the chairman of the
republican party
became the u.s trade representative and
he asked me to come run public affairs
for that
cabinet agency and that started a career
in government that went on for about 12
years
but there was one break and that was
when i
had the opportunity to be communications
director for the first president bush's
presidential campaign in 88 and
it was an absolute honor to work for him
but also to play on a national
stage i had been assistant secretary of
labor
i had a long career in politics and
government as i mentioned
but uh having the opportunity to work at
that level
uh nationally was really very exciting
i'm sure yeah um and then
uh you know he won and i went into the
white house as the white house
communications director
uh it was uh a
wild ride um and i think one of the
things that
i took from that um was to
always maintain your perspective that
this was not a permanent job the white
house
careers rise and fall overnight you have
to be able to accept that
the demands on your time and your energy
are extraordinary
you have to be able to accept that but
throughout it all i think one of the
things that served me very well
was that i had never sort of took that
job as an entitlement
that it was a job that i was privileged
to have
i was privileged to serve you know
president bush
but i knew that it was going to end at
some point
whether it was going to be two years
three years four years eight years
whatever it was gonna be it was gonna be
over
and i couldn't let myself think
that that was my you know kind of my
life and
i think keeping things in perspective
like that
helped me when you know he did not win
his re-election
right i was out of work for eight months
and
it never it never really uh
caused me you know significant distress
and i think about what's happening today
with all the dislocation that people are
undergoing
it's heartbreaking in many cases people
are losing their businesses or
their livelihoods but uh this too
shall pass and if you look at
the positives that have come from this
people that i have talked
with and you know i i
acknowledge that i am privileged
uh and have some resources
but uh the time i've been able to spend
with my family
has been extraordinary the time that
i've had to
think about
the next phase of my teaching has been a
godsend just the ability to kind of
reflect and sit back and take it all in
and think about next steps uh
you know looking at all of this not as a
threat
but an opportunity i think is incredibly
important
so professor uh what i of course forgot
to mention which i'm
trying to imply is that you're a
distinguished professor of the stanford
business school i got to take a class
with you as an undergraduate
because you so kindly agreed to teach an
undergraduate class on strategy
and really you could replace the name
strategy with the name context
between us correct but i think it's you
know it's an incredible take on what's
happening today but i have to know
you're in the white house how how often
do you go into the oval office how
how how often do you do you interact
with president bush
and what does that sense of
responsibility feel like when you know
that you're at a position that perhaps
every american
can most americans can't even imagine to
be sitting where you're sitting
well you know it's uh it's an incredible
honor i probably went into the oval
office to meet with the president
every other day wow and
now having said that the first time i
went into the oval office
when he called me in to work on a speech
he didn't like the speech that had been
delivered to him and he wanted to he was
uncomfortable with it
yeah and i got this call saying the
president wants to see you in the oval
office well of course
my heart started
and i walk in and i sit down
and he starts saying i'm not sure this
speech hits all the right notes
i know a lot of these people uh a lot of
them are
friends of mine these were ceos that
he's going to be talking to at a
luncheon and uh he says
they probably are doing a lot of the
community act
activities already i don't want to talk
down to them
meanwhile i'm sitting there and i'm
looking around the room
thinking holy mackerel i am in the oval
box he then says
okay and i realize the median's over
and i couldn't very well say to him you
know i really wasn't paying much
attention
because i was so overwhelmed by looking
at the grandfather clock and the
two seats where the heads of state sit
and
you know the the oval rug with the
presidential seal on it and all that
and so i got up and i walked out and i
thought to myself
i am screwed i have no idea how to
make this speech right and uh it's a
longer story than that but
you know uh i've taken major
celebrities into the oval office to meet
with the president
and they too are awed i took michael
jackson
into the oval office you know the gloved
one
right you walked next to michael jackson
and ushered him into the oval office
i did and uh
it was a very bizarre uh meeting
um and uh it was just it was surreal is
what it was
but how does that even work so somebody
says like as somebody who's well known
and has a lot of impact can just say hey
i want to meet with the president
get me an hour with get me an hour in
the oval office
no it doesn't quite work that way
i had one of my staff had heard from
michael jackson's people
that he wanted to see the lincoln
bedroom
he wanted to visit the white house and
see the lincoln bedroom
and we then said
let's uh up this and um
have him do a photo with president in
the oval office
well little did i know that
he was going to bring a big entourage
with him and so i had to cleave
the entourage from him and
i made him come up and meet with me in
my office first
that was sort of a bizarre meeting and
then
i i didn't ever let him link back up
with his entourage
and just took him and his manager into
the oval office this is
just didn't exactly connect with the
president uh but he did connect with mrs
bush and it was a very interesting
interaction
wow you know what i didn't know and this
is how this was the mischievous
part of president bush as he's
in the oval office he says now michael
we're going to go out and do a
what we call a photo opportunity like
michael did
uh we're going to go out into the into
the rose garden and i'm going to have a
few uh
uh remarks about mr gorbachev
and the press secretary and myself are
thinking
what he's going to walk out into the
rose garden where there's like this
enormous guideline reporters
with michael jackson and he's going to
talk about gorbachev
he walks out in the oval into the rose
garden and he announces the first
summit meeting with the soviet union
standing with michael jackson
it was a surreal moment beyond surreal
moments
and all we could think of and marlon
fitzwater the press secretary got into a
kind of a giggle about it was that we
imagined
the kgb watching this and trying to
figure out
why is he announcing this with michael
jackson
what is the significance wow and we've
got quite a kick out of it
that's just incredible george bush of
course of course
okay professor nemeris moving on you're
a head of director
your director of communications and
branding it's two of the most
incredible corporations and that really
have both critical infrastructure in
their daily lives but it really
changed the way we interact with our
financial institutions and with
responsibilities greater than just
financial institutions some of the case
studies that we've
that we've studied in our class from
your positions there just showed us how
these corporations
their their impact goes far beyond just
the exchange of money and storing our
money
that's bank of america and visa of
course what did you learn
running communications and branding for
some for these incredible incredible
companies
well i think i think the biggest uh uh
learning that i had from that experience
was to understand that
brand is much more than just a logo
brand is much more than um
presentation rand is really about a
promise
and it's a promise to customers it could
be a promise to the community
it could be a promise about social
responsibility
all large impactful organizations make
promises to
a wide range of constituencies right and
their reputation is dependent upon
whether those constituencies to whom the
promises made
believe that it has been a promised cat
and so it's changed my
thinking about how to understand
reputation how to understand
brand and in a much you know
the lens that i look at at brand
is a much wider lens right than it was
previously right um the other thing i i
think i learned
primarily at
the latter stage of my uh corporate
career
was uh how important strategic thinking
is
yes and the ability to think
strategically
and what are the ingredients for
strategic thinking and you mentioned
context that is
a key ingredient ingredient a rigorous
understanding of context
and then understanding how one action
creates another action talk to me a
little bit about this talk to me about
this little about this chess game of
understanding
because you know throughout the course
almost at every case study
we we understood in hindsight that if we
could just think a little bit further
ahead and play this chess game
internally
and realize you know there were some
instances where we were in
amazed by how you realized back then you
know in 1970
that one action is gonna lead to another
and you were able to save
six months of hardships and millions and
hundreds of millions of dollars
how how can we possibly do that sit down
and try to imagine
what the possible scenarios are so that
we can you know
avoid the hardships already
yeah i think i think one of the words
you just used is critical imagine
you have to have a a flourishing
and thriving uh
imaginary and imagination capability
right and that comes with um test
driving ideas
it comes with uh not letting the emperor
walk around with no clothes
right it comes with uh defining reality
uh looking at things with a critical eye
you know if you look at what's happened
today with this whole pandemic
there was a lot of a distinct lack
of thinking ahead and thinking
about consequence and the absence of
defining what was reality all these
mixed messages that have come
out for the last six months have been
incredibly destructive to having a
coherent strategy
and so i think that the idea of
really getting ingrained in your head
that
everything you do is going to have a
consequence and that consequence is
going to have a consequence and so forth
and so forth and so forth
and the more you're able to take that
those steps the further
you take those steps the more you're
going to land
on the right uh landing zone
uh that is going to be the most positive
sure and you know
you all of these are leadership
positions that you have quite a few
people under you and a lot of these
times
it sounds like they're more crisis
management than they are just
thinking strategically right because
you're every time you're confronted with
a communications crisis or a branding
crisis
you're the go-to guy and says david
please help us solve this
this is your time to shine how do you
how do you go about doing that i mean
you're how
how is leading in a crisis different
than leading when times are good and
you're just thinking about the next nice
project to do
well you know as you heard me say in
class you know the best crisis
management is to avert the crisis in the
first place yep
so that means a lot of thinking about
where
are the potential crises right you know
they're they're all out there they're
all these landmines out there and if
you're able to identify them early
you can navigate them up with
more skill however that doesn't mean to
say that
you can avoid every crisis right i think
the important thing
in in crisis management well there's
several things
one is something called uh deliberate
calmness you have to create an
environment for yourself
that is deliberately calm so that you
can ask the right questions
right and a lot of times in a crisis
you'll watch people run around
thinking that what are we going to do
what are we going to do what are we
going to do
and they haven't asked the most
important question which we said a lot
in class which is okay what do we know
what do we know and what do we need to
know
exactly and so if we ask the right
questions
and we do so in a thoughtful
calm organized way
you'll not only be able to navigate
through the moment
but you'll also be able to understand
what the ramifications
are longer term mckinsey
calls that integrative
integrative thinking the kind of
thinking that you can
simultaneously think about what you have
to do in the moment
at the same time you're thinking about
the implications for the future
and that's what we really needed
in this current environment were people
that could do that
i think it's incredible you know every
time we walked into class and we
received the case study ahead of time
and we were so pumped we were discussing
for hours my good friend santiago
before coming to class and we come in
and and all of a sudden you say okay
wait wait stop
what do we know what do you need to know
and then and then we let and then the
second half was only okay how can that
we now use this information
to to process through this but it's not
just jumping in and
with the first instinct just acting
professor you're looking at now
you know this global pandemic it was at
least to me very apparent in the tech
community
that almost every company and every
institution decided to deal with things
differently also in terms of
universities
you have universities that have that
until today have not decided on what's
happening next year
you have universities that have already
decided that they're closed next year
for physical studies
and you have universities that have
already said they're open so
it sounds like they're you know globally
there's not really a strategic strategy
for communicating with the public of
course looking at governments it's it's
very
similar what is what's your take on this
what does it take in from a government
or an institution to power through a
crisis
that we don't we just don't know what it
is we just don't know what the ending is
well first of all you have to um
communicate
coherently and consistently and
that includes communicating what you
don't know
okay and i think that early on
there were a lot of uh leaders uh i
won't get into too many specifics but
there are a lot of leaders
who communicated about things they knew
nothing about
right and made assertions and comments
that were confusing to the public you
had some leaders
and i would say some of some of the
governors uh
i think uh showed incredible
uh forthrightness and calm
and uh i think of somebody like governor
cuomo
in new york every day very impressive
yes and saying what they know
what they don't know uh what are the
practical steps
what are the responsible steps he also
uh was a moral leader about
what were people's responsibilities yes
and practice what he preached
all of those things go into having a
an ability to mobilize
not just public opinion but public
action and
so that people weren't uh
demonstrating in the streets they
weren't you know
uh resisting uh
what was calm and deliberative
leadership
definitely i mean you look at new
zealand just as another case study
the prime minister standing every day
and i watched quite a few of those
because i was just inspired
every time she had a question and then
she looked
to the doctor on the right and said i
don't know this do you know this let's
write it down let's check on this and
we'll come back to you tomorrow and the
next day she would come back to it
that's leadership to me the leadership
taking ownership of what you know what
you don't know
and over communicating not under
communicating i talked to quite a few
through this show i talked to quite a
few
ceos of companies both large and small
and
one one thing that constantly came up is
this idea of always over
communicate never under communicate
especially in a time of crisis
and that trust that you're building it's
and
and i think we talked about this quite
quite a bit about in bran in the context
of branding
it's you gain the trust along the way
with the actions you do it's very easy
to break the trust
to do a single right yeah well and
you know the other thing is that now
more than ever
given that communications don't take
place in a vacuum
there is this communications environment
that we live in today
of social media and highly partisan
media that is out there
fomenting misinformation disinformation
some of it's accurate information but
how do you know how do you tell the
difference
well that's where you need government
leaders corporate leaders
to be more thoughtful so that they can
command
the public's attention when they're
sending mixed messages
who does the public turn to for an
authoritative source
there is no one right definitely no
that's i mean it's incredible professor
right before we leave i want to get you
know your overall
insight i'm looking at myself
as a young entrepreneur i am very
excited to one day start my company
hopefully sooner rather than later
i'm even more excited to be in one of
your classes hopefully as a gsb student
myself one day
but if you could give me you know one or
two key pieces of advice looking forward
from your you know enormous career both
in corporate in the public service
but also at stanford which you run
communications which i didn't even
mention
what what should i take with me over my
next few decades
as i aim to be a leader myself i
think about three things and you know i
think best in threes
yes one is always
uh find your colleagues people that
you're working with
uh that are worthy of respect
you want to work with people that you
respect right
second always find something that allows
you to grow
intellectually perhaps financially but
most importantly that is going to drive
your intellectual curiosity
and keep it vibrant and and thriving
and finally you know knowing you as i do
i think i would say
always make sure you're involved in
something beyond yourself
so that it's bigger than you and
that will i think give your life and
your career
that much more purpose i love it and
definitely i think having this a
one-on-one here and
everything that i've learned from you
and i want to thank you again for for
the incredible incredible course that
you taught us and for all the
inspiration i think that it's
you know it's one thing as a class to
come in and show you that we're
learning and that we're progressing and
we are enjoying it but
but i have to tell you that outside of
the classroom then the number of
of meaningful discussions we've had and
the the thoughts we shared on how
inspiring this was uh it really i think
changed a lot of our
a lot of our thinking in in the context
of what it means to be a
person who thinks trash strategically a
person who looks at a problem understand
understands that it's
bigger than just you know the 100 words
written on the page
context is everything it's all about
what we don't know as much as we what we
know and what we need to know
in order to feel comfortable solving the
the the puzzle
so thank you very much right before we
leave three words that best describe you
um optimistic
um principled
determined i love it professor demarest
thank you very very much enjoy your time
in florida enjoy your time with your
family
and i look forward to seeing you on
campus one day good in person
okay you take care of michael take care
thank you for the time